So I wanna talk a little bit about
Germany's universal healthcare system today,
and I wanna talk a little bit about the history of it.
Now, of course,
if you are German,
this will not come as news to you.
And I do this because my previous video
was slightly misunderstood by some individuals,
thinking that I was doing something similar to Jules
in the vibe,
when in reality
it was simply a sarcastic rebuttal
to her original video,
pointing out that a lot of Europeans
have similar values,
and this has impacted a lot of the things that they do.
So, without further ado,
the universal healthcare system Germany.
So the former chancellor
Autophone Bismarck
established the first healthcare system in 1883
as a way of providing solidarity among the insured.
All insured persons,
regardless of health risk,
would contribute a percentage of their income.
And these contributions would, of course,
then entitle those contributors to benefits
based on their health needs.
And this was regardless of their socioeconomic status,
their ability to pay,
and lastly, location.
So higher earning individuals
support lower earning individuals.
People who aren't sick
support those who are sick,
and people who do not have children
help support those who do.
Now, why was this implemented?
Was implemented for a few reasons.
So Bismarck wanted to help
prevent the rise of socialist parties
by offering healthcare and benefits to workers
and their families.
And this subsequently
would also help provide more stability in the Workforce.
Which brings me to my next point.
This was a way to create a healthier workforce
and this in turn
would help contribute to the prosperity of the nation.
Healthier people means healthier workers
and potentially
healthier soldiers.
And lastly, the system was meant to be employment based.
And this was in one way
encouraging of people to go out and seek employment.
Now, of course,
in the event that someone does become unemployed,
now they are still able to keep their insurance.
But initially
this was done to help make jobs
more attractive and stable.
Now, after World War 2,
the allies actually dismantled
much of what the Nazis had implemented
in terms of healthcare,
leaving much of what was originally there intact.
And in 1992,
the German social welfare code
actually standardized to the healthcare
across a reunified Germany.
Now, is Germany system perfect?
No. Could I imagine my life without it
at this point?
Also no. And I am thankful every day
that I am able to contribute
to what is considered to be one of the most
progressive healthcare systems in the world.